welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and now that jimmy and
kimmy are a gus fringe of the past i
thought we'd we'd not only get off to a
bad start with the puns but also discuss
better call saul's latest entry the
season is ramping up to its final few
episodes and we have a big plot
development in this one with us finally
learning how our star-crossed lovers
went their separate ways i know every
single season ending explain that i've
done for the show has started with me
talking about how jimmy is dead and it's
the rise of saul goodman but here it
actually feels like that's the case from
the opening shot though he's practiced
under this name before knowing what we
do come the end it's likely that this
opening of the door and planning of the
sign cements jimmy going on the path
that we always knew he would now this
opening shot is filled with fitting
imagery of the mundane mixed with the
more horrifying aspects of their lives
they are of course just trying to act
natural and go through the routines
involving the usual things like bill
oakley getting a crap cup of coffee
whilst he makes a deal with one of them
however mixed in with this we also get
howard's blood being wiped up which is
faded into jimmy wiping up source mike
digs bullets out of walls makes literal
bullet points has the new fridge filled
up and overall it feels like everything
is back to normal which is even more
terrifying when you think about it this
idea of the devastation is clearly shown
in kim who returns home and immediately
drops their character the death of a man
in their apartment shouldn't be
something that they can just sweep under
the rug even if they managed to
literally do that jimmy tries to see the
positives and says that there will come
a day where they won't think about it at
all but we can see from kim's face that
she'll never forget title fun and games
this of course has several meanings to
it obviously it's meant to evoke a
feeling of happiness like they managed
to break away from the severity of
everything due to lalo now being dead
however the full saying is normally
along the lines of it's all fun and
games until someone gets hurt both jimmy
and kim were happy manufacturing
controversies to bring howard down and
initially they saw the humor in this
however after he was shot and killed
it's all ended up bringing the joy that
they found come crashing down now
elsewhere gerst travels out to donald's
compound where he meets with the other
heads he doesn't have anything to worry
he don't have anything to worry about as
lalo's tape in which he went off on a
latio now belongs to him but i love how
this is almost cold war feeling to the
entire meeting what better call soldiers
brilliantly is that it brings a sterile
feeling to a lot of the scenes due to
its direction though jimmy is
charismatic to a fault characters like
mike and gus are very very reserved and
clearly in a constant state of deep
thought trying to work out the angles
though he seems calm and collected gus
wants nothing more than a smash of
ladies head in like it's that thumbs up
button also you know for a fact yeah
hector and eladio would also ring that
notification bell
anyway enough of begging for likes this
it's juan bolzer hector salamanca and
the cousins marco and leonel accusations
are flying about with hector of course
well aware that gersch was behind the
mercs that attacked lalo's home hector
wants ladies to look into gus's eyes and
come to the realization that he hates
him weirdly eladio later says in the
scene that he recognizes this but he
clearly views gers as being such a big
money maker that he's willing to let it
slide
expertly directed here we see gerso's
stern outlook barely changes but in the
reflection of his glasses we can catch
the fire burning symbolizing how he
wants to set fire to the entire thing
gurst doesn't even want to respond and
due to all his planning and prep
throughout the season hector is simply
seen as a crazy old man biddly twisted
by his thirst for revenge this planning
and prep was of course seen in howard's
clean up and thanks to mike every angle
is covered gus has clearly won and he
even comes out on top and gains more
territory than before now a mirroring of
the past and future comes heavy in the
closing of the scene with gus standing
at the edge of the pool side this is the
exact same spot where his partner's body
was slumped over and he was forced to
look into his cold dead eyes this motif
of having to stare into the lifeless
face of someone whose death is somewhat
caused was also murden world looking
into hank's face this was also then
brought up in the last episode with
jimmy coming face to face with howard's
corpse the characters are always lying
down so they can stare directly into the
other's eyes and these deaths are always
defining for each person now this pool
is also where eladio would end up after
gerson axe's final plan against him and
as they say
it's all connected august returns home
and we discover that howard's death did
rouse suspicion however it seems like
they bought this story and for now the
case is closed kind of have my theories
that the series might culminate with
jimmy being arrested potentially even
with howard's death being thrown in
there too or he might finally grow a
conscience and let the truth come out
walt died jesse escaped and i think the
clothes for him would be great if it
ended up with jimmy going to jail saying
that though i'd love it if he managed to
escape too so who knows kim might even
snitch on him and hey might happen and
leave your theories below on where you
think it's going now in a more personal
moment we see gerson a similar name
david bonding over a bottle of red wine
throughout breaking bad there were
theories that he was in a relationship
with max and that's why his death meant
even more of the character than just
being the one of a friend he could stay
there and even invite him back to share
an extra expensive bottle but he leaves
while staber goes to get one to show him
now this has a number of reasons to it
and he clearly knows that he can't have
a personal life because getting attached
to anyone would put them in danger
throughout breaking bad and better
called saul we've seen as the rich
characters like walton gus have to live
humbly so that they don't attract
attention gus knows that bringing in
anyone would alert them to his
operations as even his home is a base
that connects to others under a network
of tunnels gurs can't live lavishly or
let anyone in unless he leaves now this
idea of being unable to be flash is
juxtaposed by the end of the entry which
we'll talk more about in just a bit in
that we catch up with saul's circa
breaking bad in the lavish mansion that
was shown at the start of episode 1 in
this season he even has a golden toilet
and can clearly show this off because
he's obtained it using quote-unquote
legal means swear that's not a pun now
guts has truly destroyed any chance of
having a personal life and elsewhere we
get a touching moment with mike he tells
nacho's father the truth about his son's
death and he promises justice whether
his father questions this instead
suspecting that what he really means is
revenge at howard's memorial service we
see several photos of him having fun and
though we hear all the kind words it's
clear his reputation has been destroyed
even the law firm is getting renamed due
to howard and chuck being gone showing
how much saul destroyed their legacies
jimmy being gone along with them is also
cemented by rich who calls him saul
instead of his name
jimmy uh so
now the pair both go to howard's wife
cheryl who refuses to shake jimmy's hand
and she goes off on him for the
harassment that he carried out she also
gets him to say what he told the police
and though he goes into his bcs mode obs
mode he's enabled to hoodwinker this is
when kim steps forward for the final
time and ever the pro delivers a
devastating story that will forever
destroy howard in cheryl's eyes due to
the setup earlier in the season cliff of
course also witnessed something similar
and sadly it puts the final nail in his
proverbial coffin that means no one
remember him as how he was in the car
park i feel like it finally comes to an
end between kim and jimmy with this
beautiful line before it being used to
set up their standing but it's over
i mean really over kim says nothing she
just gives jimmy a kiss and withdraws
from the lord profession itself now
jimmy being unable to convince another
woman is seen in his attempt to tell kim
to stay with him and continue being a
lawyer however much like cheryl she sees
through the lies in deceit and no longer
wants to be part of it after coming to
the realization that both enable the
other to be their worst selves she wants
to get out of it she reveals that she
knew lala was alive and that she didn't
tell him because of his ptsd she knew
that that would make them break up and
she was having too much fun but now the
fun and games are over now either way
it's devastating heartbreaking and she
finally accepts that they are poison
whatever way you cut it they led to a
good man's death and in his place rises
another good man a sore good man baby
now at this point we get a major time
jump in the series with seoul waking up
in the mansion that was taken apart at
the start of the first episode at his
side as a lady of the night and he wakes
up to the sound of journey singing any
way you want it bit on the nose but i'll
allow it his entire life is turned to a
hollow and materialistic existence in
which there's no real lover care rather
making breakfast for kim he's now
offering breakfast bars and everything
including his hair is now on the decline
i love this little comb of a shot and we
even had a clip that focused on his hair
medication in episode 1. jeans is
thinning massively on the top and the
hair loss progression is some nice
attention to detail now when this takes
place we don't know exactly but it's
likely either during breaking bad or
just before the events of the show
seoul's lawyer up played has november 5
dated on it and his barking matches 08
which is when the original show started
gone is his classy sign from the
beginning and it's replaced by attackier
one with the inflatable statue of
liberty there we end with him sitting at
his desk and putting down his world's
best lawyer mug as he waits for his
first client of the day throughout the
series we've had the world's best lawyer
flask that ended up getting second
written on it this was because kim was
the first however with her now out the
picture everything has fallen on saul
who's now seen as the top one in his
desk we also see the match books which
were important items in breaking bad
this shot is of course deliberately set
up to mirror the one with ghosts early
with a glass of wine and there's a real
sense of tragedy to it the pair both put
their work above everything else and are
now alone because of this now it's a
brilliant way to close out the entry and
come the next one i'm actually expecting
walt and jesse to show up i don't know
if we'll ever revisit the better course
or timeline but it does make sense that
we're gone from that now due to the
events of the previous entry and also
this one with lalo's death happening it
would be pointless to hang around there
and i'm interested to see if this
re-contextualizes the main show it would
be great if we heard things about the
mysterious heisenberg and saw from gus's
point of view how we learn about walt in
more detail there's going to be lots of
things to look forward to and if you
enjoy the video i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it also just to let you know
i've featured in a video talking about
all the movies that you need to watch
before nope comes out which will be
linked on screen right now now we are
also running a competition and giving
away three copies of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now see if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavy spoilers you want some emails to
watch then make sure you check out our
writing of episode 8 which will be
linked on screen right now we talked
about all the subtle things in it how it
all kind of ties together and just why
the death of lalo is so impactful if not
then hopefully i see on the next one
hope you enjoyed the video as well you
take care yourself peace